in this video I actually want to go over
the eight steps of the TCA cycle in the
last video we mentioned the pyruvate
dehydrogenase complex being the
activation step to get pyruvate into the
form of acetyl co a which can actually
go through the TCA cycle so the TCA cup
TCA cycle like I mentioned was eight
steps so just know before you begin the
watching the video that if you see a D H
anywhere in an enzyme name that means
dehydrogenase it's just me being lazy I
won't write it all the way out another
thing if you see a pink star that means
that that enzyme will be Alice directly
regulated and I'll make I'll write this
note in later anyway so once we have an
acetyl co a the two carbon molecule one
it's activated ready for the TCA cycle
is going to order the GC a cycle so the
first step is acetyl co a a two carbon
molecule joins up with oxaloacetate
which is a four carbon molecule to form
citrate which is a six carbon molecule
now no toxic acetate structure note here
note this part here CH 2 Co - right CH -
a carboxyl group that's the R group for
aspartate notice that the only
difference between oxaloacetate and
aspartate is that this carbon here this
alpha carbon at in s part 8 that would
have the the Alpha amino group and
hydrogen Excel acetate just has that
that carbonyl group there so that's a
simple way to remember the structure for
oxaloacetate anyway when these two
things come together we have two carbons
here four carbons here that come
together to make six carbons so we
didn't lose any carbons we didn't add or
remove any carbons
however this co a is no longer on
citrate so the co a coenzyme a is gone
so in this reaction we lose a coenzyme a
what's the name of this enzyme here well
we're making citrate this is citrate
synthase and this step is actually Alice
directly regulated and the reason for
that is because it's actually in a sense
the first committed step of this pathway
once we have citrate we're going to turn
it into isocitrate which is basically
just an isomer of it the only thing that
really changed if you notice that this
carbon up here had a ch2 and this carbon
over here had a no a scroop so they
basically just switched places one of
these H's came down and then the O H
went up there so they traded places so
we didn't add or remove anything all we
did was I summarize it this enzyme the
enzyme that catalyzes this reaction is
called a connotates now that seems a
little bit weird where why would it we
call it a Cana tastes the reason why is
because between citrate and isocitrate
there is an intermediate called a
cognate 8 so the enzyme is named for
that intermediate it's a little bit
confusing but there is a reason for that
name once we have isocitrate the third
step what we're going to do is we're
going to take isocitrate and we're going
to convert it into this this next
molecule down here which is alpha
ketoglutarate so what happens here
this step is catalyzed by ISO citrate
dehydrogenase again I'm just going to
write D H so what's the difference
between these two molecules well here we
had six carbons now we only have five
carbons we lost a carbon somehow let's
see what switch carbon did we lose this
carboxyl group is the same this this
here was a hydroxyl group and now it's a
carbon or a carbonyl group so first of
all this isocitrate was oxidized so and
that makes sense given this
dehydrogenase step here so I'm in the
other video I mentioned that the part of
the reason of the the TCA cycle exists
is to make nadh and fadh2 s in this step
we actually since we oxidize isocitrate
we're reducing nad plus to make it NADH
but where did we lose a carbon well if
you look at this carbon here this carbon
had a carboxyl group on it now just as a
ch2 so we actually lost a carbon dioxide
in that step now we're left with this
five carbon compound okay
and again isocitrate is another
allosteric we regulated enzyme
now now we have alpha-ketoglutarate and
it's going to be turned into sucks
Tinoco
so alpha q - good right - sucks in Ocoee
this enzyme the enzyme that catalyzes
this reaction is called the alpha keto
polluter rate dehydrogenase complex so
dehydrogenase means we would expect an
alpha or C me I read a redox reaction so
we would expect to see that alpha
ketoglutarate was oxidized and that is
actually the case the difference here
between this this molecule here in this
molecule here is that we got rid of this
carboxyl group we replace it with a co a
so we must have added a cleanse i'm a so
we added a co ash and this carboxyl
group flew off and notice this carbon
was bound to a car carbon up here but
now that same carbon is bound to a
sulphur so for a slightly more
electronegative and more bonds to a more
electronegative atom atom is an
oxidation so that means something else
must have been reduced again this is
another reaction in which we create nadh
from nad plus okay and of course we lost
that carbon as a carbon dioxide another
Alice strictly regulated enzyme what I
want you to notice is that three of
these four reactions that we talked
about so far this one here is I just
trade the hydrogenase the alpha
ketoglutarate dehydrogenase and the
pyruvate dehydrogenase complex step that
would happen here before the before the
reaction to happen all three of those
right all of them release actually not
all of the four three of the four
release carbon dioxide right that means
they're irreversible which which is why
their Alice directly regulated citrate
synthase right is the fourth one that
one is in a sense a commit
it's step because it's the first it's
the first step of the pathway right so
that's why that one's regulated but the
other ones are all regulated because
they're irreversible because they
release a gas carbon dioxide maybe let's
continue so once we have this sucks in
Ocoee the next it's going to be turned
into succinate which you'll notice it
looks a lot different the way I've drawn
it here but it really isn't too
different here we had a cop officer
group to see h2s and then a carbonyl
here we have a carb officer group to see
h2s and a carbon dioxide so all we did
here was we got rid of this coenzyme a
and we made this a carboxyl group so how
did we do that the enzyme that catalyzes
this reaction is a look at a funny name
it's called suction L Co a synthetase so
it was actually named for the reverse
reaction another one of those kind of
annoying names it's a little bit
confusing sometimes too to understand
what's going on there so in this step
we're getting rid of that coenzyme a
this coenzyme a does not exist over here
in succinate so we're losing a coenzyme
a in addition this reaction going this
way is a very exergonic reaction so
exergonic in fact that we actually in
this in this step we actually create
energy and we create it in the form of
GTP so we're going to make a GTP and
from from a gdp and an inorganic
phosphate so we're gonna take a gdp and
inorganic phosphate and and and put them
together to make a GTP so we're actually
gaining an energy out here um and note
we saw the same number of carbons no
carbons gained or lost so the next step
we're going from succinate to fumarate
so what happened here we still have four
carbons all we did was we got rid of two
hydrogen off of this carbon and a
hydrogen off on this carbon and then
made a double bond here so this here if
you have less bonds to hydrogen that is
also an oxidation or you can think about
it as more ball
to a more electronegative atom here we
had bonds to hydrogen now we have bonds
to carbon carbon is slightly more
electronegative than hydrogen so
succinate was oxidized to fumarate so we
would expect this enzyme name to have to
be a dehydrogenase and it is it's
actually and it's acting on succinate so
it's succinate dehydrogenase now on this
step we would expect to make it NADH but
we don't within this is the step that
actually instead of making an NADH we
start with an F ad and make an F ADH -
so if section a is oxidized fi D is
reduced now how do you remember that
this is the step that creates the fadh2
because all the other steps in which a
redox reaction occurs we create NADH the
way I remember is that going from
succinate you you make a fumarate
fumarate starts with the letter F so as
fadh2 so the reaction that creates one
thing that starts with the letter F also
creates the other thing that starts with
letter F I mean that's helpful to me I
don't know if will be helpful to you but
if it is great and if it isn't do
whatever you need to do to find a
helpful way to remember it so then we
have step 7 going from fumarate to male
8 so notice all we did here was we added
a hydrogen to this carbon right to get
this just and then an O H to this carbon
to get this so we're adding an H and an
O H essentially we're adding water here
so we're going to add water ok the
enzyme that catalyzes this reaction is
called fumer ace because it acts on
fumarate notice we haven't changed the
number of carbons in a very long time we
still have a four carbon molecule so now
with male 8 what we're going to do with
male 8 male a is going to be turned back
into oxaloacetate so this is why this
thing is called a cycle right we're
going we started off with oxaloacetate
we go through all these steps and then
we regenerate oxaloacetate so in order
to get from Mele to oxaloacetate we need
to turn this Oh H into a carbonyl right
so we
need to oxidize it so male 8 gets
oxidized again we would expect a
dehydrogenase step and that is what we
have this is male 8 dehydrogenase that
catalyzes this step and the
dehydrogenase so we would expect to
create another nadh male a is oxidized
nad plus is reduced to make an NADH so
what happened here this this whole
process we started off with a co co in
an oxaloacetate then we go through right
and OH what we do is we regenerate that
four-carbon oxaloacetate in this whole
process
meanwhile we're also creating a bunch of
nadh is and we even create a GTP and we
also create an fadh2 so those are the
steps of the TCA cycle I hope that was
helpful thank you for watching